[Applause]
hello everyone it is time for Drew's
news Ross Matthews is out of the desk
today and joining me here is my new
co-pilot the end for the entire show the
Grammy nominated talented entrepreneur
philanthropist who once likes the bottom
of a pair of sneakers on an episode of
MTV Cribs it's our friend of the show
Fat Joe
seeing the Seekers had never been used
yeah yeah I was trying to I've had I had
those sneakers for about seven years so
I try to show people I collected them so
long and never used them so I licked the
bottom of it right that's like the first
going viral ever now when I was with you
last you gave me a tour through your
home uh Borough the Bronx last season we
had so much fun look that's us
um and Joe you gave me those very
special sneakers and I have to say I'm
proud to tell you that they are so
scuffed up like I wear them all the time
let me tell you I took Drew through the
Bronx and everybody went crazy for Drew
I they were crazy for you projects
everywhere everywhere in the hood and
everybody was like yo true yo Choo yo
trust it
wow
wow and they're hosting the upcoming bet
hip-hop Awards
what are you most excited about what are
you nervous about what are your thoughts
I gotta be honest with you drew this
takes me back to the talent shows in the
Bronx I used to do in junior high school
and I waited all my life for a moment
like this so I've been rehearsing I've
been going over everything I've been
like looking at the house all day
yesterday I was just picking out outfits
with my uh stylist Tyrell are you going
to do changes oh no every single time
the camera comes on there's a change
give him a show that's what people want
yeah I'm definitely going to give them a
shot you want to hit some headlines all
right
thanks to our San Francisco Bay
affiliate kpix 5 for bringing us this
story Jordan Orozco a math teacher at
Deer Valley High in Antioch California
is showing his students that it's hip to
be square root Now by turning his
lessons into wraps take a look
[Music]
Pythagorean
triangles keep it 180. circles they go
for 360. and just like pie I plan on
going forward
he is getting rave reviews from his
students who say the Rhymes make it
easier for them to remember Concepts
that used to trip them up I mean Joe
thoughts man let me tell you I love that
guy man and and he understands his
students and he's getting to them and
he's showing the math in the fun and
cool way so salute to the teacher and he
said that was the one line I had in the
movie night school with Kevin Hart was
Pythagorean theorem
[Laughter]
[Applause]
uh next up the Kim Kardashian update we
all been waiting for
CNN entertainment reports Kim has shared
exactly what she's looking for in a man
she recently broke up with Pete
Davidson and while she's not currently
looking she did say she feels whatever
she's doing quote clearly is not working
so next time she wants to go for a
scientists
neuroscientist biochemist doctor
attorney nerd man
your time has come true have you ever
dated a scientist I would
I mean I have nothing to do with Kim
Kardashian's life
um but an attorney seems like an
exciting prospect because she's so
invested and her father was an attorney
and she you know has been studying like
crazy and she's you know using her
platform for Injustice now and is
talking about the wake-up call of like I
have this 300 million followers I want
to lead them to these meaningful stories
I think she's in an incredible evolution
of her life so maybe someone who Fosters
that would be inspiring to her it's
fascinating I'm glad she's sharing it
with us
and as always
I'm wearing my skins
story what a snapback Drew oh guys guys
if you've been wondering how to update
your wardrobe look no further than the
hottest new trend in men's fashion Ken
koi AKA dressing like the Ken doll
that's right the Wall Street Journal
reports Ken core has taken off admits
the excitement of the Barbie movie
premiering next summer starring
Margaret Robbie as Barbie and Ryan
Gosling as Ken I love Ryan if you want
to dabble into this trend experts
recommend starting with pastels and
building up to bold Neons or just dive
in with the easiest way to embrace can
call go Beach blonde yes
I mean you're dressed in bright colors
today
I love this I love that the mat the
glasses match the um sweatshirt Bottega
baby bold yeah baby now Joe we did take
the liberty of mocking up maybe what you
would look like in some Ken chords you
want to look yeah I want to see that
I wish
I wish all right finally a little
segment we love called every day is a
holiday
okay and today is National Coffee Day
well how many people here like coffee in
the audience
everybody perfect so you guys are all
gonna get a hundred dollar gift card for
America's original coffee Gourmet
Macy
[Music]